es común que las personas con presión
arterial alta y niveles anormales de
lípidos también sufran de diabetes tipo
este vídeo explicará cómo el sufrir
todas estas condiciones puede afectar su
salud y lo que puede hacer para reducir
el riesgo de diabetes tipo 2
si tiene presión arterial alta significa
que la fuerza de la sangre que empuja
las paredes de los vasos sanguíneos es
demasiado alta su corazón tiene que
trabajar más duro cuando su presión
arterial es alta algunas personas con
presión arterial alta desarrollan
diabetes tipo 2
si tienen niveles anormales de lípidos
en la sangre puede significar que tiene
demasiado colesterol ldl también
conocido como colesterol malo
o bien puede significar que no tiene
suficiente colesterol hdl también
conocido como colesterol bueno
o bien su nivel de triglicéridos también
conocido como la grasa en la sangre
puede ser demasiado alto puede tener más
de una de estas anormalidades de lípidos
al mismo tiempo
las personas con niveles anormales de
lípidos tienen una mayor tasa de
diabetes tipo 2
la diabetes tipo 2 es una afección en la
que su glucosa en sangre o azúcar en la
sangre está elevada
con el tiempo un nivel alto de azúcar en
la sangre puede dañar los vasos
sanguíneos de su corazón y otros órganos
lo que puede ocasionar otros problemas
de salud
sufrir presión arterial alta niveles
anormales de lípidos y diabetes tipo 2
puede afectar los de muchas maneras
tendrá un mayor riesgo de sufrir otros
problemas de salud graves como
enfermedad coronaria un ataque al
corazón un accidente cerebrovascular e
incluso la muerte es posible que
necesite ayuda en cuanto a cuidados
personales es posible que también deba
tomar más medicamentos
y vivir con estas condiciones puede
causar depresión
la buena noticia es que hay cosas que
puede hacer para ayudar a reducir su
riesgo de desarrollar diabetes tipo 2
por ejemplo puede que sea necesario
realizar unos cambios en su estilo de
vida
si fuma obtenga la ayuda que necesita
para dejar de fumar
mantenga o alcance un peso saludable
siga un plan de alimentación saludable
que incluya alimentos bajos en grasa y
bajos en sodio y trabaje con su
proveedor de atención médica para
determinar la cantidad correcta de
actividad física para usted
asegúrese de trabajar con su proveedor
de atención médica para controlar su
presión arterial y sus niveles de
lípidos esto incluye tomar medicamentos
según lo prescrito por su proveedor de
atención médica
el seguimiento del plan de tratamiento
acordado entre usted y su proveedor de
atención médica le ayudará a sentirse
mejor y a reducir su riesgo de
desarrollar diabetes tipo 2